Mohamad mirandy we were speaking to
before is the head of the American
Studies department at the University of
Tehran we were speaking to him before
unfortunately we lost the line he's been
good enough to stick around and come
back to us now before we lost you you
were essentially saying that you
consider the u.s. action today a
declaration of war just pick up that
thought and explore that for us yes I I
think it's clearly an act of war the
United States has murdered a senior
military official in Iran a person well
known a person who is highly popular in
the country the United States is also in
my opinion carried out an act of war
against the Iraqi state and the Iraqi
people because they have also murdered a
Booma Dilma and this who is a senior
Iraqi military official that is a part
of the Iraqi Armed Forces the Americans
of course will justify this act of
terrorism and war but it's there's just
no comparison with anything else that
the United States has done over the last
few decades they've this is targeting
the Iranian people it is targeting the
Iraqi people and I in my opinion Western
citizens should leave the region
immediately if I was in the United Arab
Emirates in Iraq or elsewhere I would
think of leaving as soon as possible
Mohammed taking your comments there
about an direct act of war but then
contrasting that with what we hear from
the United States the Pentagon says that
here was someone who's considered a
terrorist heading a terrorist
organization who had already overseen
attacks against American interests and
American people and was planning further
attacks given that and given given the
targeted nature of this strike targeting
this particular individual and another
does that really mean a declaration of
war against Iran or was this a targeted
action against someone declared
a terrorist the United States is not
authorized to dictate terms to the
international community
just because an American leader or the
American regime says that someone is a
terrorist is not make him a terrorist
this is not the 19th century this is not
the height of the Western Empire where
they dictate terms to the periphery and
to the colonies Iran is a sovereign and
independent country Iraq is a sovereign
independent country
awesome Soleimani general Qasim
soleimani is a an Iranian national hero
the Iranians consider him as martyrs
overwhelmingly Iraqis consider him as a
martyr he was the person who engineered
the defeat of Isis in Iraq alongside the
Iraqi armed forces including the popular
mobilization units and that's why
avimall Mohandas who is also senior
Iraqi figure is considered to be a hero
these two men are the people who have
spared the region and Beyond from Isis
that the United States through its
foolish policies has helped to create
alongside the Saudis and other regimes
in this region other terrorist groups
like Al Qaeda's which we see right now
in Italy being supported by these same
countries if it wasn't for him if it
wasn't for people like him and albemarle
Mohandas this region would be would have
black flags flying over many of the
capitals today so again for the
Americans to declare something to say
someone is a terrorist I think it's it's
ridiculous for any of us to even take
such a statement seriously and by
implication to accept American actions
resulting from such statements now III
hear your assessment of the United
States and how you see its role in the
region let me put a counter assessment
about Iran that we hear often
Iran is expansionist in the region Iran
involved in countries like Yemen it is
involved in the proxy war there against
Saudi Arabia through its groups like
Hezbollah in Lebanon it continues to
ferment unrest and to seek to expand its
influence it is actively hostile to
Israel it is sought to impose itself on
Iraq despite Iraqi people rising up in
protest and saying they don't want Iran
to dictate their future it is just in
the past we carried out military
exercises with Russia and China that the
United States in its latest strategic
assessment says are the two most
significant threats directly to the
United States so if we look at that and
we look at the u.s. actions towards Iran
and Iran's actions in recent weeks
wouldn't it be right for the u.s. to say
we have to defend our interests and the
interests of our friends and allies in
the region against Iranian aggression
well you have to give me a few minutes
here first of all who started the war in
Yemen who invaded the country who
imposed starvation on the country was
the United States and Saudi Arabia that
have carried out crimes against humanity
and the Europeans were just as complicit
who invaded Iraq who armed Saddam
Hussein in the first place who gave
Saddam Hussein chemical weapons to use
against the Iranians and his own people
it was the Europeans in the United
States who then attacked Iraq and
destroyed the infrastructure who then
imposed sanctions on the country where
up to a million people died under those
sanctions who then invaded Iraq and
destroyed the country it was the the
American regime that did that who is
continues to act with impunity in Iraq
and murders Iraqis soldiers who are
fighting Isis it is the regime in
Washington who created al Qaeda in
Afghanistan who created the Menace that
brought about 9/11 it is the United
States who supported the extremist
groups in Syria who destroyed Syria who
is responsible for the rise of Isis al
Qaeda Jaysh al-islam and others such
terrible evil groups that are Wahabi
oriented funded by Saudi Arabia who the
Israeli regime allowed to be based
alongside
their borders with Syria alongside the
gola occupied Golan Heights in fact who
invaded Lebanon Hezbollah was created as
a result of the Israeli invasion of
Lebanon and the destruction of the
country Hezbollah expelled the Israeli
regime from Lebanon it is a National
Liberation Organization so when we look
at the region we see American bases in
all the countries such as the Emirates
such as Iraq such as Syria illegal
American bases in Syria as we speak to
steal Syrian oil where the Iranian bases
where the Iranian bases in Iraq if Iran
is expansionist where the Iranian flags
in Iraq in Lebanon in Afghanistan in
Syria Iran's presence in all in all
these countries are with the permission
whenever they've been present ins here
in Iraq of the governments in order to
fight these extremist groups that the
Americans helped to create look at the
Defense Intelligence Agency documents of
2012 which admits that the United States
and its allies supported the rise of
these extremist groups in Syria they
helped them to gain the territories
between Syria and Iraq the same group
that we now call Isis so it is the
Americans that are guilty of destroying
this region and beyond this region look
at Libya the destruction of the country
training it into a failed state the
Menace of Western countries in this part
of the world and the rest of the world
is nothing new colonialism and
Eurocentrism and hegemony and empire
have been a part of this reality that
we're living in but now the United
States has gone too far it carried out
an active war against a sovereign
country they've carried out an act of
war against two sovereign countries and
those regimes that stand by the United
States in this act of war they will have
to pay the price and just on these the
consequences from this because clearly
we're at a point now where the nighted
state says one thing Iran says something
else we've seen this action today Iran
is saying that there will be a response
to this what will that respond
be and are we in an escalation phase now
of this conflict that ultimately may
play out as a proxy war itself within
Iraq without due respect this is not one
side says one thing and another side
says another the United States
assassinated a senior government
official in Iran and assassinated a
senior government official in Iraq this
is a act of war that is recognized
across the globe simply because the
Western media will mimic what the regime
says in Washington doesn't make it any
different from what I said these are
acts of war and therefore they will pay
the price I do not know what the
response will be
I think the Iranians and the Iraqis and
others across the region are discussing
that as we speak but if I was in the
Emirates I would leave now if I was an
American in Iraq I would leave now if I
was an American any part in Southwest
Asia
I would leave immediately thank you for
that Muhammad Muhammad rod is joining us
there from Tehran appreciate your
analysis today